in preparation for hurricane season it'd
be a good idea for livestock producers
to review their their health program
because there's always the potential
that animals may be relocated to a
shelter or another farm to get them out
of dangerous way and the other situation
that could arise is you know storms can
do a lot of damage not fences down and
potentially then in that situation
animals could go mingle with other herds
as well and just be exposed to other
infectious diseases so so having a herd
health program up to date having
vaccinations up to date would be a good
thing another situation that that could
arise is when animals are commingled
trying to get them back to their proper
owner so animal identification is very
important and it needs to be unique
animal identification something that is
specific to that animal into that farm
and so for example hot brands USDA II
mental ear tags electronic
identification tags those would all be
potentially unique animal identification
as opposed to say a dangle tag with just
a number on it you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of black cows in Alabama
that probably have an ear tag number 26
in their ear for example so it needs to
be something unique to that particular
animal so that that people can get the
animals back to their to their proper
farms of course making sure that you
have all the equipment on hand that you
need to to respond to to a potential
disaster making sure that you have feed
and water available and in storage for
one to two weeks potentially for stored
feed it needs to be stored in a dry safe
place and it needs to be someplace
that's that's fairly secure so that you
do have good healthy wholesome feed to
provide your your livestock after a
disaster if you're on a well water
source having hand pumps or generators
available in case electricity is
disrupted would be would be all the
important things to consider ahead of
time livestock producers should
prioritize their animals so that they
can be sure that those
animals if animals do have the
opportunity or the need to be evacuated
those animals with a high priority can
then be evacuated first or looked after
first if the producer knew which animals
were maybe getting ready to cab or a kid
or fall whatever the case may be put
them in a location where they can maybe
check on them
first to make sure that there haven't
been any complications or any issues
that arise during the during the storm
if you are in an area that is prone to
flooding
for example move move your animals to
higher ground and ideally keep them out
of barns they're usually going to be
better left in large open spaces as
opposed to confined to the barn the last
thing you want to do is put your animals
in there and then have the storm destroy
that building with all your animals in
it so they're usually going to be better
off on high ground in large open spaces
particularly if the horses are not used
to being out in the pasture in that
situation it may be safer and a better
idea to leave them in a stall in a
secure building because last thing you
want to have happen is a storm to come
in scare the horses frighten the horses
and and they you know don't know how to
handle that don't know what to do and
they may end up injuring themselves more
so than the storm
you